this
is china's tallest skyscraper and one of
wall street's biggest financial firms
has snatched up more office space here
while at another one of the city's
glossy towers
jp morgan's rival goldman sachs is
expanding headcount
not just in shanghai but across china
over the past few years the discourse
from washington has gotten increasingly
sharp about splitting ties with china
whether it's around trade we will end
our reliance on china or technology
huawei's not coming here we may be
banning tick tock
but it's a different story on wall
street despite the u.s and china body
hats on issues such as
trade and technology one sector that we
have seen a lot of commitment from the
u.s to china
is finance american firms are expanding
in china to tap its 47 trillion dollar
financial market
so why is wall street doubling down
despite washington's rhetoric to cut
ties with china
the short answer is china's financial
sector has never been as
open for business as it is now and wall
street has been waiting for this moment
for nearly 20 years
despite a global pandemic and chinese
investment in the u.s
down by some 90 percent over the years
wall street is pouring money into china
to access the largest
untapped pool of capital in the world
when china joined the world trade
organization in 2001
it promised to open up its financial
services
let us make our due contributions to the
development
and strengthening of the multilateral
trading system
over the years foreign firms have been
allowed to enter china under certain
conditions
such as allowing them to hold minority
positions in joint ventures with chinese
companies
or managing funds for only wealthy
investors
but 2020 was a year when beijing let its
store swing more open
with this signing we mark more than just
an agreement we mark a sea
change in international trade
as one part of the u.s china phase one
trade deal
foreign companies for the first time
could manage money for
any chinese investor foreign banks can
have majority or even full control of
their local
securities and futures unit this means
that foreign financial firms can finally
tap into the vast market that they have
long
coveted and that's music to ears for
many wall street firms
which can finally make decisive steps to
grow in key industries
including asset management which is
forecast to be the second largest in the
world by 2023
however it's not smooth sailing foreign
firms still have to comply with the host
of restrictions
foreign financial firms still have to
navigate a complex
regulatory region applying for licenses
and demonstrating that they have a good
track record
in the fields they are operating a new
cyber security law also requires firms
to keep clients data
in china which exposes them to potential
government security checks
this also puts u.s firms in a position
of having to balance a different set of
ethics and data protection
for clients at home versus china
besides foreign players will face stiff
competition from homegrown companies
chinese financial institutions have
really moved up quite rapidly over the
past few years
benjamin quinlan runs a financial
consulting firm in hong kong
as you can see over the past few years
they've obviously established
a very dominant position in the market
you know for example the top eight
chinese securities firms
make up significant amounts of market
share
financial market has been protected for
decades and foreign firms are going up
against domestic companies
some of which are also state-backed that
already offer some of the same services
they have a lot of financial and balance
sheet firepower
knocking them off that purge is going to
be a very tough task for any
international financial institution
also u.s companies betting big in china
could become caught in political
crosshairs
just look at huawei and tiktok which
have become entangled in u.s and china
trade talks and security concerns
complicating business operations and
deal making
meanwhile chinese leaders are working on
a blacklist of foreign companies
the more that china integrates with the
international financial markets and the
more that the global financial
institutions
are operating in china the more
difficult
it will be for that i would call it
split or that trade war divorce to occur
despite the risks wall street seems
unfazed
while much of the u.s is still writing
out the pandemic and working from home
in china firms like jp morgan and
goldman sachs
have already returned to their offices
the chinese economy is poised to come
out of this crisis
much better and faster than the west so
if you're looking at where to naturally
place your bet as an organization
there's no i would call it economic
rationale to not continue with that
[Music]
strategy